artmann fährt fährt herbeiführte
hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute mal wieder glätte allerdings nicht
das normale gold besonderen gold mmo
simulator was das ist weiß ich jetzt
noch nicht genau wir sehen hier wieder
die tollen tipps eingeblendet und jeden
moment sind wir genau hier im golf
simulator sie einfach mit dem
benutzernamen luca jetzt die ziege sieht
auf jeden fall ganz schön geil aus wir
können auch akrobatisch die jury ich bin
auf die können nicht wirklich eine
mikrowelle steuern okay ich bin als
mikrowelle was mache ich hier ich war
zuma obendrauf zu klären
das hat super geklappt ich weiß auch gar
nicht was soll das ich kann überhaupt
nicht hoch springen ich bin
sorry bin ich eigentlich grad mit
anderen mischproben bin ich eh grad in
einer mit spiegel oder kann ich kann
nicht wirklich wissen meine macht es ich
kann eine pizza aus hier rausschmeißen
was kann ich denn noch machen ich kann
mal eher drücken um
erwartet man hier auf ihn geschaut wir
jetzt kann ich hier hoch gehen und sehen
wo was was soll das wir sind eigentlich
überall alter deutlich dass mal eine
pizza hin
die fliegt einfach direkt in der
richtung nein ich kann nicht weiter ein
mein gott ich habe eine quest erhalten
ich bin gerade in der schneeflocke
fabrik und jetzt bin ich auf dem weg des
abenteurers und wir erleben zusammen
das tolle
wo bin ich halt zu euch fragt was luca
dotti me later macht er hängt auf einem
baum herum bevor ich bin einfach eine
verdammte mikrowelle ich war wie mache
ich das immer das ist einfach viel zu
krank ich verstehe dieses spiel gar
nicht das ist einfach kein gummi mehr
sondern das ist einfach ein normaler
crazy simulator was ist das da unten für
ein kranker typ würde ich nicht mal
theoretisch mit ihm hier das hat sie gar
nicht war doch erst umgefallenen baum
nein er baut sich wieder zusammen meint
abgelaufenen von dem baguette was wir
uns in den ofen geschoben
kumpel ist kati und wer muss zu bargeld
gemacht deswegen musste das gasthaus
nehmen
typisches luca video aber ich habe noch
einen geheimpakt wie ich den hier auf
jeden fall stoppen kann und zwar was
sagst du dazu diese pizza
ich hänge ich kann nicht weg
kopierschutz ganz langsam an und
ich glaube ich bin tot wir sind gerade
im schwanz der meerjungfrau wie krank
sie das bier bitte aus alter ich bin
einfach irgendwo im paradies gelandet
oder so das ist einfach viel zu geil
dieser mmo bin ich jetzt
ich glaube eine mikrowelle wert aber
schon längst tot oder schaut euch mal an
wie geil das hier aussieht
ich mag ich auch nicht ihr könnt auch
wer ist ein typ der auf dem boden von
bargeld da macht euch keine sorgen um
mich ich stecke den zaun sowie du
brennst soll ich dir mal
ich kann den zaun kaputt machen luca
ich glaube normalerweise müsste man hier
mit leuten wie reden weiß ich aber
ehrlich gesagt hat nicht genau wie das
theater das sieht hier ja alles nur so
nice aus wie überall so tische und alles
das ist doch gar nicht mehr richtig gut
sie mir later oder die welt hier ist
einfach unfassbar richter ich komme da
gerade überhaupt nicht darauf klar ich
kenne bisher nur über diese gold zu
milito welten die ich glaube die welt
ist jeder zu ende ich kenne bisher immer
nur diese codes simulierter welten die
halt wirklich dann irgendwie nach 23
minuten laufen in eine richtung vorbei
sind aber die hier ist einfach was ist
das hier kann ich nicht mal rein
theoretisch die kraft in meiner ganzen
fähigkeiten anwenden um diesen schwer zu
zeigen was zu wem ich in der lage bin
meine damen und herren damit würde ich
sagen dass das spiel für heute beendet
ist weil ich nicht genau weiß was ich
machen soll das einzige was wir machen
würde ist oder horsemen benny mal rein
theoretische irgendwie wow das war super
wenn euch das video gefallen hat bin ich
mich über die bewertungen freuen wollte
mehr co2 shit blatt schreibt ihr tipps
für blätter wie ich irgendwie doch
krasse sachen machen kann in die
kommentare und dann sehen wir uns
irgendwo wieder